die kameras warten schon versprochen
wurde ein promi der sich in moskau mit
dem russischen impfstoff sputnik wie
impfen lässt und auch wir als
ausländische medien dürfen ausnahmsweise
in der klinik dabei sein
der versprochene promi ist einen
russland mehr oder weniger bekannter
bodybuilder und blogger alexander speck
jetzt bekommt er seine dosis sputnik ein
letztes elfi noch vor der impfung mit
einem impfstoff von dem man noch nicht
genau weiß ob und wie er überhaupt wirkt
es hat mich niemand überredet das zu tun
es ist immer gut der erste zu sein ich
habe ihn vorher immer negativ gesehen
hier aber ist das was anderes ein halbes
jahr lang wird alexander jetzt von den
ärzten betreut um die wirkung von
sputnik wie zu beobachten
er glaubt dass der impfstoff wirkt vor
allem aber liebt der exzentrische
blogger die aufmerksamkeit und wie so
viele andere will er sein altes leben so
schnell wie möglich zurück haben
normalerweise reise ich viel ich will
normal arbeiten nicht normal bewegen
ich mag die massen nicht wirklich ich
habe jetzt die möglichkeit alle
medizinischen dienstleistungen zu
bekommen und einer der ersten zu sein
und von nun an frei zu sein
im weltweiten wettrennen um einen corona
impfstoff ist russland vorgeprescht im
august schon wurde mit sputnik wie
weltweit der erste impfstoff freigegeben
noch bevor wichtige test ergebnisse der
sogenannten phase drei vorlagen
eine große studie mit 40.000 teilnehmern
läuft gerade rund 12.000 freiwillige
wurden bereits geimpft internationale
wissenschaftler kritisieren die
vorgehensweise simeon gulp er ihn von
der ärztegewerkschaft liga der ärzte ist
auch noch nicht überzeugt er hat sich
trotzdem impfen lassen
zu recherchezwecken im november soll die
massenimpfung mit sputnik wie starten
es fällt mir schwer heute zu empfehlen
sich impfen zu lassen
soweit ich sehe und von den fällen die
mir bekannt sind geht von dem impfstoff
keine gefahr aus und sorgt nicht für
besorgnis über die effizienz ist noch
nichts bekannt
er kann sich als effektiv erweisen
aber das wird man erst am ende der
forschung ist doch präsident putin wäre
gerne der erste der der welt einen
corona impfstoff präsentiert es geht ums
prestige und natürlich um sehr viel geld
putin führt russland in corona zeiten
vor allem per video konferenz zur
ernsten corona welle hatte er das
unpopuläre krisen management vor allem
den moskauer bürgermeister und den
gouverneuren überlassen
letzte woche aber verkündete er stolz
dass vector zentrum in nowosibirsk hat
heute dem zweiten corner impfstoff
registriert er heißt die vag corona das
ist zweifellos ein wichtiger erfolg den
ihr liebe freunde erzielt hat
unterdessen steigen auch in russland die
korona zahlen rasant 15.700 fälle allein
heute nach den offiziellen zahlen
die hauptstadt moskau bleibt der hotspot
mit rund vier bis fünftausend
neuinfektionen jeden tag masken sah man
hier in den letzten monaten wenige die
moskauer coroner müde
viele ignorierten die gefahr
mittlerweile wird die masken pflicht in
der metro kontrolliert
und wer heute in einer bar gehen will
muss sich mit einem qr code oder per sms
mit seinen daten registrieren
einerseits kann man darüber lachen aber
andererseits sind die qr-codes natürlich
schon eine überwachungsmaßnahme man
überwacht eine person
man kann feststellen wohin ich gehe und
was ich tue es ist unangenehm dass
jemand weiß wo ich am abend war auch
wenn ich nichts kriminelles tun es ist
einfach nicht angenehm in den corona
krankenhäusern steigt auch die zahl der
patienten und toten
zusätzliche kapazitäten wurden
geschaffen provisorische krankenhäuser
aufgebaut
in moskau gibt es tausende freiwillige
die in den kliniken aushelfen weil
pflegepersonal fehlt sowie sergej juni
er putzt desinfiziert betreut patienten
selbst im krankenhaus drehen dürfen wir
nicht es scheint jetzt ein bisschen
ruhiger zu sein als im frühjahr aber
anstrengender als im juli
vielleicht nennt man dass die zweite
welle mit mehrere patienten seit beginn
der pandemie gibt es vorwürfe dass in
russland corona zahlen manipuliert sein
könnten und auch sergej musste für die
wahrheit kämpfen
im frühjahr hatte er sich im krankenhaus
selbst mit corona infiziert aber seine
erkrankung hätten die behörden am
liebsten verschwiegen
ich hatte schwierigkeiten weil der
korona test der vom notarzt gemacht
wurde negativ war
aber der test vom labor kam war positiv
ich hab dann an die gesundheitsbehörde
geschrieben dass mir die richtige
diagnose verweigert wird
das war mir wichtig wegen der
versicherung
sergej hat sich durchgesetzt seine
erkrankung wurde dann doch noch
registriert auch blogger alexander spath
wartet auf ein ergebnis nämlich auch bei
antikörper durch die sputnik impfung hat
oder nicht
er fühle sich gut sagt er und halte sich
fit draußen mit seinen hunden oder
drinnen in seinem fitnessraum von der
impfungen der korona zeit habe bislang
so oder so profitiert neue projekte mehr
als zwei millionen follower auf seiner
instagram seite und neue werbekunden
alexander ein corona krisengewinner sich
impfen lassen und das öffentlich heißt
maximale aufmerksamkeit
ich bekomme die aufmerksamkeit von
meinen followern und den werbetreibenden
während mich alle kritisieren verdiene
ich in ruhe mein geld viel geld fließt
in die verwandlung seines körpers und in
die pflege 25 schönheits-op es hat spaß
gemacht alles zum spaß wie er sagt wenn
es ihm jetzt irgendwann mal schlecht
gehe habe er die ärzte die versprochen
haben sich mit vollem programm um ihn zu
kümmern
darauf verlässt er sich und wenn alles
gut geht und der impfstoff wirkt sagt
alexander war ich einer der ersten
[Musik]